vous avez que david guiraud porte-parole
jeunesse de la france ainsi nice bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous sur arte france
ainsi que daniel leca conseil régional
udi de l'oise vice-président des hôtes
france bonsoir daniel leca merci
beaucoup d'être tous les deux ce soir
sur arte france pour débattre
la vraie question ce soir après une
première journée 2-2 reconfirme ans et
l'acceptabilité des français david
guiraud
quel sentiment vous avez sur cette
question on voit que déjà il ya pas mal
de dos gens qui grognent c'est normal
qu'ils grondent
on a nommé un premier ministre qui était
censé être monsieur déconfinement et il
re confine donc il ya quand même une
part d'échecs là dedans ou ça fait
depuis le 28 avril qu'on dit qu'il
risque d'y avoir une seconde une seconde
vague épidémique
on n'est pas au rac on n'est pas
prophète nous on fait de la politique et
la fonction soumises on le disait parce
qu'on me disait qu'il y avait besoin de
planifier rien n'est planifié il ya
plein de questions sur la rentrée
scolaire qui restent en suspens moi je
me demande quand même comment est-ce
qu'on peut interdire aux gens d'aller
chez le fleuriste ou acheter des livres
alors que par contre en parallèle dans
un lycée avec 200 300 ou 400 élèves
on peut les faire aller à la cantine de
tous ensemble sans masque en train de
manger
voyez il ya des contradictions que les
gens ont du mal à supporter moi je veux
le faire le confinement j'appelle à le
faire parce que maintenant évidemment on
est au pied du mur tous au pied du mur
mais je le fais pour nos soignants le
fais pas pour emmanuel macron parce que
autant la première vague on pouvait on
pouvait reconnaître que c'était
compliqué quoi voilà je le reconnais
mais la seconde vague il y avait des
éléments de planification qui ont pas
été mises en oeuvre et on demande aussi
des choses on continue à faire des
propositions par exemple ouvrir des
librairies je ne vois pas ce qu'il ya de
dangereux à permettre à ce que les
librairies soit ouvert c'est pas un
vecteur de contamination etc sinon si on
ne fait pas ça c'est amazon qui va
emporter les marchés qui va faire fermer
dans cette situation l'a conduit à faire
fermer des librairies et c'est la
culture c'est notre identité aussi en
france d'avoir cet axe est il facile et
locales à la culture et voilà on
continue à faire des propositions
néanmoins c'est une grande question est
la question des livres d'ailleurs face à
la grogne des libraires c'est la fnac ou
les grandes enseignes finalement qui ont
fermé leur rayon libre ce soir daniel
leca donc en gros en france et tout le
monde fait nous alors personne c'est
c'est le vrai enjeu c'est comment
effectivement on fait accepter cette
mesure de confinement en montrant que
d'une certaine manière tout le monde est
traité de la même manière et qu'il n'y a
pas deux poids deux mesures c'est tout
l'enjeu on est aujourd'hui confronté à
une situation qui nous impose ce
confinement on a une situation
évidemment épidémique sanitaire qu'il la
pose face à ça on a effectivement eu à
sartre d'hésitation à certain nombre de
doutes qui ont fait que les français ont
eu pu avoir le sentiment qu'on est passé
de tout à rien d'une situation s'était
effectivement beaucoup de français sont
relâchés et c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire est aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'il
ya besoin de ce tour de vis je crois
qu'il y a là aussi besoin que l'on soit
tous savent les modestes que l'on soit
dans l'opposition dans la majorité parce
que cette crise sanitaire impose parfois
que l'on agisse à tâtons et on peut
donner des bons et des mauvais points la
réalité c'est que la situation est très
complexe et en la matière sur les
questions d'ouverture ou de fermeture
des commerces il faut faire preuve
évidemment de pragmatisme vérifier et je
crois que là-dessus on n'a pas assez
fait où sont les clusters je ne crois
pas que les commerces soient des lieux
de clusters je crois que là où il ya eu
vraiment des clusters nombreux se sont
souvent dans des cadres familiale dans
les réunions de famille ou par choix
effectivement les barrières sont tombées
et on a malheureusement fait en sorte
que des personnes contaminées côtoient
des personnes qu'ils n'étaient pas
encore et il y compris d'ailleurs sur
des personnes plus âgées je crois que
c'est ce que nous allons malheureusement
connaître dans les jours qui viennent
je crois qu'il faut faire preuve de
discernement le gouvernement a fait ce
qu'il a pu dans cette phase de
reconfirmer je crois qu'effectivement il
y a besoin d'avancer progressivement et
donc le point d'étape dans quinze jours
sera aussi l'occasion de reposer les
choses et vérifier sur certains
commerces ne peuvent pas réouvrir c'est
le cas notamment des commerces de
proximité le textile par exemple il ya
aujourd'hui besoin d'avoir une démarche
pragmatique qui permettent à tout un
chacun de se retrouver dans cette époque
de confinement et de comprendre ce qui
leur arrive
ce qui aujourd'hui effectivement elle
pas toujours le cas et je crois que
c'est là le vrai problème
oui david guiraud est ce qu'à un manque
d'explication c'est vrai que le
gouvernement tombe de
et sur laon se contaminent l'eau ou pas
donc effectivement cette question des
petits commerces peu posé davantage de
questions or là ils ferment ils décident
de fermer les rayons livres je répète
dans les grandes surfaces mais là c'est
pas pour une question de contamination
c'est pour une question de grogne d'un
côté donc oui oui la logique dans ce
confinement des maires des mères aussi
se rebiffe et 10 et les commerces non
essentiels par exemple dans la nièvre ou
dans les pyrénées-orientales ne seraient
pas concernés ils ont pris des arrêtés
pour les rouvrir
et évidemment ce que vu qu on ne
planifie pas que les choses ne sont pas
organisés parce qu'ils n'ont pas voulu
croire ça vous savez emmanuel macron
nous a dit qu'on serait prêt en cas de
deuxième wagon des papes fait c'est pas
vrai comment est-ce qu'on se retrouve à
quelques jours du confinement à se poser
des questions sur l'école sur comment on
va organiser la rentrée c'est pas normal
c'est pas normal donc forcément les gens
sont tous s'inquiètent quand c'est pas
clair donc voila moi je je je je vois ça
et je trouve ça pas normal que le
gouvernement prenne mettra en place de
mesures jeudi autre chose ce confinement
il va faire très mal
on le sait à l'économie française il va
également faire très mal aux français il
ya 10 millions de pauvres dans lequel
nous nous avons fait des propositions on
demande à ce que le gouvernement nous
entende on doit ouvrir le rsa aux 18-25
des jeunes sont dans une précarité
immense en ce moment ils ont perdu leurs
petits boulots vous savez déjà ce qu'ils
font souvent des petits boulots en plus
ils sont pas forcément déclarer qu'ils
sont mal déclaré qu'ils sont moins au
courant de leurs droits ouvrir le rsa
aux 18-25 augmenter le rsa suspendra
temps les loyers étudiants par les crous
c'est facile c'est l'état pars pars pars
par contre pour les bailleurs criant on
pourrait rembourser d'ailleurs à ce
qu'on sait que tous les bailleurs privés
sont pas non plus un milliard mais voilà
des mesures qu'on demande depuis le
début et les choses doivent s'organiser
quand on a fait onze propositions de loi
moi ce qui me rend lorsqu'il met en
colère c'est que on a fait une
proposition de loi cinq plans d'action
combien a retenu le gouvernement aucun
aucun ils nous disent mais j'en ai mangé
une représentante et les roms mais hier
sur un plateau télé qui me disaient
qu'on n'y a aucune proposition que que
lobo et que les oppositions et même pas
quatre ans a soumises que toutes les
oppositions étaient était stérile mais
enfin je veux dire les républicains ont
fait leurs propositions les socialistes
les communistes consensus miss jolie à
un moment il faut écouter les gens on
nous a fait venir à une réunion
iliad où il ya trois jours on nous a
fait venir a fait venir des membres de
toutes les organisations politiques pour
leur dire des choses avec lesquelles le
gouvernement lui même ne savait pas quoi
dire le lendemain emmanuel macron fait
un discret et le surlendemain donc hier
on doit voter sur le discours à
l'assemblée nationale d' emmanuel macron
sans possibilité de vraiment inventé le
texte vous voyez bien que ça provoque de
la colère dans les organisations
politiques daniel leca seat sentiment le
fait de ne pas être suffisamment entendu
en tout cas par par les oppositions je
crois je crois qu'il ya une forme
d'unanimité sur le sujet où
effectivement le gouvernement doit doit
sans doute davantage dans les changes
dans le partage dans la co construction
avec les collectivités locales
un partenariat clair avec les l'ensemble
j'allais dire des parties prenantes les
départements les régions les communes
chacun doit pouvoir prendre sa part dans
ce dans cette période compliquée en
l'occurrence on sait très bien que l'on
va effectivement se retrouver dans
quelques semaines en quelques mois
face à une situation économique très
difficile et pour affronter cette
période il faudra une forme d'union
sacrée de l'ensemble des partenaires
économiques et sociaux pour faire en
sorte que l'on puisse sortir le pays de
l'ornière dans laquelle elle saura il se
retrouvera nécessairement on sait qu'on
a le mur de la dette qui est en train de
s'ériger devant nous l'ensemble des
plans de soutien qui sont nécessaires on
ne peut pas laisser tomber les
commerçants et ceux qui sont obligés de
fermer ou de réduire leur activité
c'est une évidence mais néanmoins il va
falloir que l'on anticipe que l'on
prépare les choses sur la dette sur la
relance économique et donc ça nécessite
une forme d'union sacrée et oui le
gouvernement doit apprendre à travailler
de manière plus horizontale avec je le
disais les collectivités locales mais
aussi effectivement toutes les forces
politiques et des forces syndicales de
ce pays nous avons besoin de ça nous
avons besoin de ce travail horizontale
si nous ne le faisons pas effectivement
les mesures que l'on sera amené à
prendre dans les semaines qui viennent
ne seront pas acceptés par les français
or c'est ça l'enjeu c'est
l'acceptabilité et la légitimité des
choix qui seront faits dans les semaines
qui viennent
je crois qu'il ya dans le pays des
forces de bonne volonté qui sont prêtes
à contribuer
à cette réflexion est à mener ensemble
les réformes et les prendre les mesures
qui sont utiles mais encore faut-il
effectivement qu'il ait cet échange qui
est des dialogues et j'allais dire que
ça dépasse évidemment la question de la
crise sanitaire
c'est aussi une question qui peut
concerner naturellement la question de
sécurité des questions de terrorisme où
il ya besoin dans notre pays de
davantage du dialogue et des changes
dans une logique d'unanimité qui
effectivement aujourd'hui n'est pas dans
la méthode du gouvernement david guiraud
il ya déjà des préavis de grève déposés
justement dans les collèges et des
lycées à partir de lundi
là c'est le manque de préparation et ses
fameuses demi-classe que réclamer les
professeurs là aussi il manque de
communication bien sûr mais vous savez
moi ce qui m'a choqué c'est que dans le
discours d' emmanuel macron et aucune
annonce sur les sur les enseignants
alors que ce qui a priori on regarde les
annonces dans le sens qu'elles veulent
mais en gros il ya les soignants et puis
il ya les enseignants qui franchement on
être sûr mobilisés sur cette période de
confinement qui voit que le corps de
métier qui va être le plus mobilisé avec
celui des soignants y est je suis un peu
le premier lors vous preniez confinement
emmanuel maintenant a fait des annonces
pour les soignants rien n'a eu aucune
pour les pour les enseignants pad il
n'est pas question de revalorisation
n'est pas question de conditions de
travail
moi je vais vous dire une chose les
classes à 35 je les ai connus quand
j'étais jeune comment vous comme un
train comment vous pouvez faire quand
vous n'avez pas de perspective quand on
vous dit pas que b peut-être que là on
va pas faire en un jour mais que quand
même dans dans quelques années on va
changer cette logique-là à l'école de
toujours faire des économies sur
l'éducation nationale c'est ce que
demandent les professeurs aussi et puis
en termes d'organisation les médias
moi je m'excuse mais le travail n'a pas
été fait ccp 10 les soigner les
enseignants le travail n'a pas été fait
c'est à dire qu'après une planification
ya pas eu là les protocoles aujourd'hui
n'ont pas changé et on se retrouve dans
une situation où le gouvernement oublie
mais oui mais il ya moins de
contamination à l'école parce qu'il ya
des protocoles c'est pas ça la réalité
la réalité c'est que on n'a pas testé
les enfants parce qu'on a considéré que
soit ils étaient immunisés soit ils
étaient moins porteur du virus à la
science peut le dire je veux bien
l'entendre mais on les a pas testé et on
a considéré que vue pour les tester pas
il y avait quatre clusters mais en fait
on n'en sait rien et un enfant qu'elle
comptait y est c'est un enfant qui peut
contaminer sa famille derrière donc
encore une fois moi je repose la
question pourquoi
des cantines à plusieurs centaines de
jeunes et aux panneaux fleuriste et nos
librairies c'est quand même eu une
question de bon sens les restaurants
pour faire une comparaison égale david
guiraud un mot on finit par part vous
évidemment sur cette question de
l'éducation nationale on annonce
évidemment des restrictions mais après
on demande de les mettre en oeuvre est
ce qu'on prend pas les choses à l'envers
selon vous je joue je ne voudrais pas là
dessus sur ce sujet un peu de hauteur il
ya une cette crise a révélé beaucoup de
nos lacunes et ça c'est une réalité dans
le domaine médical dans le domaine de
l'éducation
on a aussi effectivement vu qu'on était
vulnérable sur l'organisation de nos
services publics et qu'il y avait besoin
de remettre beaucoup de choses à plat la
période de crise est jamais facile de
pouvoir effectivement posé les débats de
manière apaisée et le faire de manière
de manière transversale mais c'est
l'occasion de le faire je crois que vous
avez évoqué la question de l'éducation
vous avez raison il ya eu du tâtonnement
et ce tâtonnement était néfaste et il
accuse inquiéter les professeurs c'est
le cas dans le monde médical et je crois
que sur tous ces sujets il faudrait
reposer les bases de ce qu'est notre
service public de ski à son efficacité
de ce qui nous permettrait de mende
affronter ce type de crise parce que
elles pourraient se reproduire de
manière beaucoup plus efficace
cette période on va on va vivre là je le
crois dans quelques jours
malheureusement dans le secteur
hospitalier une vague qui va remettre
une nouvelle fois notre système à dure
épreuve bas de mettre à l'épreuve sur le
système de l'éducation nationale c'est
la même chose essayons là aussi de
reposer les bases d'un débat apaisé et
n'ayons pas de certitudes ça vaut pour
la majorité comme pour l'opposition
j'entends vous parlez de planification
et et encore une fois ce manque
d'humilité les français ne le
comprendront pas vouloir organiser c'est
une chose mais les français ne
comprennent pas non plus que nous
puissions avoir des avis aussi tranché
alors qu'on voit bien qu exercer le
pouvoir c'est pas pareil que de
commenter c'est plus difficile
et sur ces sujets j'essaye d'être humble
et modeste
et encore une fois je ne me sens pas
appartenir à la majorité mais j'essaye
d'être d'être cohérent et de délivrer un
message aux français à il faut qu'ils
soient responsables et qu'ils aient
aussi une éthique de la responsabilité
individuelle
il faut qu'il soit prudent pour eux
mêmes et pour les autres tout à l'heure
vous
évoquer le fait qu'il fallait respecter
les gestes barrière pas pour le
président magnon ça c'est une évidence
il faut le faire pour chacun d'entre
nous et pour tous les autres c'est d'une
logique de solidarité s'était placé
important c'était de la lacc les
respecter david yala 2000 vraiment 10
secondes non mais très rapidement c'est
pas une certitude c'est jusqu'au bout
d'un moment quand vous avez les
communistes jusqu'à jusqu'au général de
gaulle qui pratiquent la planification
c'est pas une certitude c'est juste
qu'on sait que ça marche et on a dit on
à avoir la bonne écoute là on est sur un
virus effectivement une situation
nouvelle à laquelle ils sont confrontés
tous les pays du monde
merci beaucoup merci daniel leca merci
david guiraud on en débattra bien sûr on
aura le temps
avec cette nouvelle période de
confinement et qui va durer un mois je
vous le rappelle merci en tout cas
d'avoir des battus ce soir sur notre
antenne